well the music medic or dr feelgood
kishan bedalia is with me now uh lovely
to talk to you this morning so what came
first wanting to be a doctor or wanting
to be a dj
the truth is i think they both happen
side by side throughout school i always
jumped to becoming a doctor i i
pushed all my studies and exams towards
reaching that dream but whilst i was
doing that i was playing instruments
like saxophone piano clarinet and
producing music for my bedroom so yeah
the truth both happened at the same time
um and then nhs sessions started during
lockdown just talk us through that how
did that happen
well at the very start of the pandemic i
was living on my own and it was
obviously a very emotionally difficult
time we were working long hours and
because we were i was feeling quite
isolated on my own i needed to do
something to make myself feel good but
also to entertain my frontline nhs
colleagues and everyone else who was
stuck at home in lockdown so i decided
to dj sets in my scrubs for my kitchen
and just see what the reaction would be
and the reaction was absolutely
incredible and now has reached millions
around the world been picked up by
record labels and huge names like fat
boy slim i mean that must be really
heartening to
one have all those people watching you
but also getting all this support and
seeing that it's had a really positive
impact
yeah and one of the most special things
to me is being able to grow a platform
and push positive inspiring messages
encouraging people's physical and mental
well-being also being becoming the face
of campaigns for the nhs and for
companies like sport england to get
important messages out there to keep
people happy healthy and smiling
what's it been like on the front line
for you how busy have you been
it's been it's been very different over
the course of the pandemic there's been
times where it's been incredibly
challenging for example at the very
start or this time last year when i was
redeployed to the intensive care unit
we've had ways where it's been
very very difficult a relentless
workload and yeah feeling a lot of
pressure um there have been times when
say rules have eased and that's because
we've been finding things a bit less
difficult in hospitals um but at the
moment obviously things are different
different hospitals where i'm at we are
seeing higher numbers of admissions but
this is reassuring that these numbers
aren't as high as in the past
such high case numbers as well and but
my main concern at the moment is
staff going off sick and this is why
we're going to feel more pressures over
the next few weeks
how have you managed to balance
doing your job and obviously doing your
dom under quite a lot of pressure with
also doing the djing i mean i guess the
clubs haven't really been open the same
way anyway
well actually music is something i've
done all my life so
even during medical school in my free
time or when i need some down time i'd
be making music in my bedroom or djing
to myself to my friends so it was
exactly the same thing during the
pandemic when i'd come back from shifts
at 9 or 10 p.m i'd go behind my decks
because that was my way of unwinding and
when the pandemic began they sort of
restructured our roads so that i was
working more hours each day and i've had
more days off in between shifts that
meant i could focus those days on on
building this nh sessions brand and sort
of building my platform on my instagram
at bedalia dj just to get this message
out there that music can make you dance
and feel happy
well it certainly can and a lot of
people have really missed not being able
to go out dancing and not being able to
go to nightclubs there's been a lot more
dancing in kitchens hasn't there over
the last couple of years
100 and i think we've actually reached
millions of people on some of my live
streams on my instagram we've had
hundreds of thousands of people tuning
in just to one live stream and i've been
overwhelmed by this to me this is crazy
how me from my kitchen
can
reach that many people in their own
kitchens across the uk or i can
collaborate with an influencer who's
running a workout and i'll be dj ended
up doing the workout or i'll collaborate
with a chef who's cooking food
all supporting that message of promoting
physical and mental well-being so i just
want to keep building this platform and
reach as many people as you possibly can
but as well as being in your kitchen
you've also been out and about and in
the uh new year's parade in london this
year it was of course a lot smaller than
youth parade than it has been in past
years uh what what did that feel like
honestly it's probably one of my
favorite gigs i've ever done i was doing
a dj set from london in waterloo place
it was an amazingly sunny day and my dj
set opened the parade to 500 million 500
million viewers worldwide across the uk
us it was actually it was a dream come
true and just to see people in the
audience having an amazing time but
knowing that this is impacting other
people was incredible
oh congratulations with that and you're
going to play us a bit before we leave
aren't you is this your new single
my brand new single for calling for you
it's my debut release that i've signed
to one of my dream record labels for
smash the house and yeah i hope you
enjoy you can stream on spotify so enjoy
there you go
[Music]
is
[Music]
dj vitalia uh thanks very much it's a
bit early for a glow stick for me um but
it's really great to see you and great
to hear you
new tune and what you've been up to
thanks a lot